[Music]
if a man falls who writes
another the support but woe to the man
alone because when he has fallen there
will be no one to pick him up
there is hope for the one who
remains in the  light of the living
rescued by the scientist he will raise his
head
here the costs repeat the big names
in medicine
pastor ehrlich leicester curie
how many diseases we thought were
incurable diabetes thirty years ago it was a
slow death but then in toronto  banting
and pest find a cure
insulin tetanus yesterday tetanus kill but
quitta sato is a japanese find the
cure lane amy pernicious once
meant certain death but from
boston to mesh finds
murphy note and weppes le
forte wins  already won
science turns against
the most formidable opponent who is still in the
running
[Music]
and
[Applause]
not
[Music]
but m
a ball and a simple strip that
three men  s scrutinizes a photograph of
human tissue
[Music]
here is a man whose organism is
undermined by a strange evil but above
all the very body of this man
how was it formed
[Music]
in the beginning the  human and
fertile egg and it's a whole life in a
pinhead
it's a cell
with a potential to grow
to grow by dividing
[Music]
from one to 2
2 to 4 by the fundamental process of
life mitosis
4 8 16 and this until the
next infinity after destination the cell
turns into embryos
[Music]
in the embryo that believes the cells
differentiates
seventh week and the embryo already consists of
2 million  of cells grouped
according to their character
this one for the hand
this one for the eyes
[Music
] others morph from the heart spreads out into a
choir adults
[Music]
and
and from the embryo the adult finally emerges
he is a compound  of billions of
cells group and in systems that
allow it  ent to live to work and
to procreate
these are the muscles
the waters
[Music]
delicate network of blood vessels
the pains the arteries
[Music]
the tireless muscles of the heart
the intestinal villi which
absorb food
the cells of the liver which stores
sugar as well  and by so many other
secret and wonderful processes crosses
the cells
the man a harmonious living entity
reaches its invisible border the one where
these cells stop growing
and if it does not stop if for some
obscure reason their growth resumes
without brake or  law if it divides
again then betraying the organism of
which they are a part it crosses
beyond all normal compressing
healthy tissues and organs it crosses
[Music]
they infiltrate the whole organism
where they establish their
malignant colonies  it crosses blindly
ransacking the vital functions of
the body
it's cancer
[Music]
why the problem of c  ancer remains
so obscure this cell won't
stop growing this we know
but why why can't we
find the cause
the greatest brains in the world are
working on solving the problem
but why is it good
why the answer  tel escapes us
[Music]
because this tiny cell this
microscopic unit is a universe to
explore
[Music
] science sinks into this universe
in these infinitesimal spaces where it
discovers constellations of which it
draws up the map with strange names
the  center in the hands
[Music]
the mitochondria
and
the network of golgi
cytoplasm
the nucleus or nucleus of the cell
the chromosomes
[Music]
the nuc the men map of a
miniature astronomy that it took years
to draw up this  are worlds this ready
or sense in gravitation in each
cell is there millions of
cells in the human body a
pinhead which is a universe is there
that the mystery of life and
the enigma of cancer lie
[Music]
in a vacuum a particle of cherves
survival time impose an end to all
living being life to all is limited
10 years 20 years 50 60 but a fragment of
its  flesh can survive animal
survive and
grow nowadays a fundamental point in
the study of cancer and the experiment
on living tissues on normal as well as abnormal tissues
in many cases cancerous cells
intersect in their prison of
glass without losing any of their malignancy
graft on the appropriate animal but would
kill it
but these fragments deprived of their
nourishing organism they need to be
raised to feed them a rigorous technique
they require infinite precautions to survive
they must be
fed even in a sterile atmosphere
they must be provided regularly with
invigorating solutions
in this way healthy tissues to
cancerous tissues can be preserved as needed
these tissues can also grow  be
in eggs but always under specific conditions
cancerous cells are injected
into fertilized eggs they
interbreed feed on the embryo
laboratory animals can
also be used as culture grounds
for cancerous tissue the devices
here may seem simple  the
techniques seem elementary but it
took years and years
to develop
them hundreds of samples
thousands of hours
for many reasons the researchers
prefer to experiment with tissues
taken from the animal
how style reacts to  various
chemicals at diet change
what is the difference between
normal tissue and cancerous tissue
infinity question
mark growth rate can be measured
is recorded step by step like
donkeys or trunk  tree
and in every cell of this
growing living mass lies both
the challenge and the response
[Applause]
cha  that cell has a nucleus is a
center on the ground
enclosed in the nucleus are the
tiny elements that
govern heredity
the chromosomes that transmit
the characters to the daughter cell the
mother cell when the fateful moment arrives
the astral body divides
[Music  ]
the entwined chromosomes
split apart
what was one becomes 2 with a
common heritage
[Music]
and
julie have a family tree that
no man has from one generation
to another
the brothers and sisters have been  to be coupled
to the point that we can almost
absolutely predict the
family characteristics of each of them acquired on
these mice will have cancer then 9 out of
10 of their offspring will have it and
so on
and yet it is possible to give
birth to a mouse  very reluctant to
cancer
but men
for men nothing definite is
established on the heredity of cancer from one
generation to another
for the researcher the study of
genetics it is the e  exploring the
full range of life from mines to
guinea pigs to mice to possible
application to humans
when science can say with
certainty what role genetic factors
play in cancer
in humans that day we  we will have
reached a peak
the experiments on mice to be
conclusive require years of study
but it only takes a few weeks
to follow the life cycle of the
drosophila the fruit fly in ten
months know that we can observe nearly
thirty generations
he looked into the mechanism of heredity
and found that the chromosomes that
transmit heredity can be
changed by forces outside
the cell you can place a
normal fly under a bombardment of x-
rays these rays strike in the manner of  an
electric hammer which can
alter chromosomes so profoundly and
subsequent generations will produce
new and various variations
mutant species garlic creatures
atrophied es monsters and its variations
can appear in various animals
in mice for example
mice tumbling zuri twirling
these acquired characteristics can be
transmitted from one generation to
water cancer and that it posed by an
alteration of the chromosomes
[Music]
the world of the cell is a prodigious
complex which responds to all the
requirements of the girl and of
growth it breathes
it
nourishes transforming
and manufactures
it is used
which combine
prodigious complex of life life
and  the growth
[Music]
the vital functions of the
normal cell and the cancerous cell
are they
analogous did we know could we stop
the spiral of the cancerous cell
in these glass tubes is
cancerous tissue taken from a rat the
cells  cells breathe under the eyes
of scientists analyze the gases inhale
and
exhale major research that is continuing
in laboratories around the world  tier
research on the processes of life
in living cells
normal cells and cancerous cells
[Music]
and
[Music
] patience time tenacity
it is not without difficulty that we access the
why of  things to knowledge
to understanding to clear answers
there are no easy answers to the
big and baffling questions
[Music]
no
can a foreign body invade the
cell and change its behavior
we begin to grasp the  relationship
between the surrounding environment and the onset
of cancer
the researchers to put together this
gigantic puzzle dig into the past of
known patients they follow a trail we
have found, for example, that those who
spend their lives in the open air are
constantly exposed to the sun's rays
too predisposed  to skin cancer
more than those who work from
the inside but there are exceptions
why
[Music]
when we have enough of a clue we
can  establish preventive measures
but we need facts
carefully collected effect from facts to
hikes statistical studies that
we can analyze and compare
[Music]
any promising leads and
identify types of families
the history of trades a thousand cases
will reveal  is there a common factor
are some cancers more common
in certain industries the trend
she says
the statistics it sheds some light
on the mystery are
some cancers more common
in men than in women
statistics  broke up to study is
there something in our
daily labor that triggers
cancer science interrogates all suspects
samples collected from
hundreds of places to detect in the
end the murderous element
oo
that progress since 1918 date or
Japanese scholars caused a
tumor to arise by smearing
a rabbit's ear with tar since that time
scholars have deco  discovered hundreds of
cancer-causing compounds and assembled models
of their molecular structure
applied to everyday life
research into the effects of
common chemicals may help
prevent cancer but other
questions arise  the science how
and why chemicals
cause cancer what actions
it exerts on the cell
questions to be answered
[Music]
and the answers appear through
this dogged research a man can
look to treatment with confidence
many things are possible
today that they were not
a few years ago
[Music]
every day that dawns brings its
progress
[Music]
in the laboratories behind the walls
of the hospital more precise tools
forge  hopefully more
effective weapons exploration of
old and new songs continues
treatment with radium patient labor
of discovery and perf  activation of
tiny tubes
mg of radium applied to the
cancerous tumor dosage of radium its quantity
and its strength still
meticulously studying
[Music]
radioactive isotopes
atomic energy placed at the service
of humanity certain cancers that of the
thyroid for example seems  recoil from
this new technique
the geiger counter in the
electric crackle by its indicated intensity
measures the radioactive elements and
enters through the body to the
customer carbon sodium phosphorus
radioactive new name around
which research is busy on this fund
of  acquisition comes to support the
treatment of cancer patients
[Music]
in the field of radiotherapy
very high voltage devices give
more effective and more penetrating radiation
precision attention test is countered
provence
china like an entire train
[Music]
mr davis will heal
but  not everyone has the same
luck there are sneaky cancers whose
the symptoms are revealed late that they
do not cause pain at first which
lurk in the body
and yet day by day the
surgery tracks them further and
raises hope the majority of cancer patients who
will present this year will receive  an
effective treatment
but you have to detect the cancer in time
that's why
science is stubbornly looking for the means on the test which will
track the cancer as soon as it is
still curable
[Music]
yes
these twenty years of study  what
a man needs since his first lesson to
become a scientist he
is a man like the others but
whose intelligence has been mobilized
and his imagination sharpened he has enriched himself
with the vast reserves of the
world's scientific treasure
in him  tirelessly closing a
happy problem who can know the why of
things
there are these men everywhere in the
world in montreal in washington in new york
in paris in london in rome in geneva in
stockholm
what is it  man for you to
lean over him like this
[Music]
[Applause]
behold a challenge has been issued and accepted
dark search for a ray of light
that can spring from anywhere from
the faceted eye of a  fly or
dollar said that of a plant because cancer
attacks all girls blindly
[Music]
on its tables on seven others in this
laboratory in this other everywhere
we are looking for an answer
[Music
] day by day towards  progress
is across the whole world the
pursuit of an idea the exchange of
new
and heavy knowledge will shed light on this
problem
from the dawn and what generation for this
so vast problem of life
against cancer the state  of siege and
declared
soap professors students all
highly qualified and equipped with all the
science and techniques of the 20th
century tackles the problem the
discovery will not be the work of a
single man in the final day the conquests
the failures even of  other scholars  eur
will be procession and when finally the answer
will be fine they have ventured very far
into the labyrinth of a
3d universe this cachet observes
wii which embraces us all is inevitable
dring sum à modeque de berin mende
leweb'10 line she can give our
managers  slick featherweight
greenhouse
the mayor can't be taken
there it sucks it's a battlefield
where science advances to victory
[Music]
you
and